.
IT WAS. A CHALLENGE THAT WE
NEEDED TO GET OUT IMMEDIATELY.
THE CURES ACT TO HELP TO
MITIGATE CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
PEOPLE IN TERMS OF WEIGHT
REPLACEMENT. ROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT WERE
ADDED. TO THE WEEKLY
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT. HAS
OFFERED I NOTE SOME OF.
CONFLICT BUT BUT HERE'S THE
REALITY OF IT THE REALITY IS
YOU CAN'T QUIT YOUR JOB TO GET
AN EXTRA SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS. A
WEEK. BUT SECONDLY KNOWING THAT
THE PANDEMIC. WITH THIRTY
MILLION AMERICANS HAVING FILED
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THAT
THE CONTAGION OF THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM WOULD MAKE ITS WAY
INTO THE CONTAGION OF THE
ECONOMIC SYSTEM PEOPLE HAVE
TROUBLE PAYING THEIR RENTS AND
PAYING A MORTGAGE THAT'S WHAT
THIS WAS ABOUT. AND THE WEIGHT
REPLACEMENT ISSUE ALONG WITH
THE EXTRA SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
HAS GONE A LONG WAY TOWARD
AMELIORATING SOME OF THAT. THAT
PRESSURE. THE OTHER SIDE KNEW
THIS WAS COMING. THEY KNEW THAT
EVENTUALLY. DESPITE THE
PROCRASTINATION THE ARGUMENT
THAT THEY WERE WAITING TO SEE
HOW THIS WOULD PLAY OUT NOW
BRINGS US TO THE EVE OF AN
ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE IF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS NOT
EXTENDED. YOU CAN SEE THAT-
RIGHT NOW THAT THERE'S GREAT
UNCERTAINTY. THE CONFRONTS THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM. AGAIN A RECORD
NUMBER OF COVID CASES THE
RESURGENCE OF THE PANDEMIC OUR
RESEARCH THE RESURGENCE. OF THE
VIRUS IS AGAIN CAUSING GREAT
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY. IT'S LIKE
THE CHILD CARE IT'S LINKED TO A
CHAOTIC SYSTEM OF HOW STATE'S
DELIVERED UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION BUT WHAT IS
IMPORTANT NUMBER IS. TO THIS
MOMENT THE UNITED STATES SENATE
HAS REFUSED ACT. COMPLACENCY
WOULD BE THE WORST STRATEGY TO
ADOPT RIGHT NOW. I THINK OF ALL
THE ISSUES THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
PUT TOGETHER THE CARES ACT.
INCLUDING THE RETENTION TAX
CREDIT UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AIDE FOR OUR HOSPITALS. WHAT
WAS REALLY THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
ENDEAVOR WAS UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE LARGELY BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF
LIQUIDITY IN THE SYSTEM AND
BECAUSE PEOPLE THE SUSTENANCE
OF DAY TO DAY LIFE. IT ALSO
HELPED TO CREATE CONSUMER
DEMAND THOSE WITH IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS. WE CAN'T LOSE
THE MOMENTUM THAT WE DEVELOP IN
THE CARES ACT BY NOT GETTING
IMMEDIATELY. TO THE HEROES ACT.
THEY CAN'T SAY THAT THEY
HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO THAT THIS.
TWO MONTHS IN TEN DAYS THEY HAD
TO GO THROUGH THIS. THE
EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC. IT WASN'T GETTING
BETTER. IT REACH THE CEILING
FOR A WHILE BEGAN TO SLOW DOWN
BUT I WOULD REMIND ALL OF THE
GOVERNOR OF CONNECTICUT IS
TAKING A DIFFERENT POSITION
TODAY THE GOVERNOR OF
MASSACHUSETTS TAKING A
DIFFERENT POSITION NOW GONE OUT
OF STATE VISITORS AND THIS IS
PART OF WHAT WE FIND OURSELVES
WHETHER IT'S IN CALIFORNIA
TEXAS. OR FLORIDA. THE TRUTH IS
THAT THE RECOVERY IS GOING TO
BE SLOW LARGELY BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL IN THE STAGES OF
STABILITY AND RELIEF. SO I
THINK THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ISSUE. IS NOT ONLY
COMPELLING IT'S OVERWHELMING.
AND DODD CHAIRMAN DAVIS IS HAS
HAD A GREAT DEAL TO DO WITH
THIS. ODD HE HAS SAID TIME AND
AGAIN DURING OUR GET TOGETHERS
OUR RESUME CALLS. HE BELIEVES
THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE DID.
AND HE'S REALLY MADE A BIG
CONTRIBUTION TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT HELP TO WRITE
THIS. GERMAN VEHICLES. THANK
YOU TO NEIL. YOU KNOW THESE
PAST MONTHS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
WITH UNBLINKING CHARITY. THE
IMPACT OF SYSTEMIC RACISM ON
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR SOCIETY.
I'M NOT GOING TO MINCE WORDS. A
REPUBLICAN FAILURE TO CONTINUE
THE SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR A WEEK
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT SUPPLEMENT
WOULD REPRESENT A RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY ACTION PERIOD.
ANY WAY YOU CUT IT ANY WAY YOU
LOOK AT IT. AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND LATINOS MAKE UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE. OF THE
CENTRAL WORK OF THOSE
HOSPITALIZED BY THE VIRUS. OF
THOSE DYING FROM THE VIRUS ANY
OF THOSE FACING EVICTIONS TO
JUST SIMPLY STAY IN THEIR HOME.
WE CANNOT ALLOW REPUBLICANS TO
TAKE A COLOR BLIND POSITION ON
WHO IS HARMED BY CUTTING OFF
THE SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
SUPPLEMENT BUT UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS. I'M INDIVIDUALS DON'T
WORK. BECAUSE THEY CAN WORK.
THEY CAN'T WORK BECAUSE IT'S
DAY. FOR THEM TO WORK. THEY
CAN'T WORK BECAUSE THERE IS NO
WORK. AND THEY CAN'T WORK
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CHILD CARE
FATHER. NO PLACE TO TAKE THEIR
CHILDREN HOUSE PRESS THAT
EXTENSION OF THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS BACK IN MAY. IN THE
SENATE REPUBLICANS AND
PRESIDENT HAVE YET TO ACT WHILE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS. TEAROOM
THE A- WONDERING WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN TO THE NEXT WILL THEY
BE ABLE TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE
NEXT WEEK THROUGH THE NEXT
MONTH. I REJECT THE IDEA THAT
WE COULD LET THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS SUPPLEMENT. EXPIRE IN
JUST GIVE WORKERS SOME HELP
AFTER THE FACT. ONE THING I
KNOW IS THAT RETROACTIVE
BENEFITS BUT NOT THE SAME. YOU
CAN'T EAT RETROACTIVE. YOU
CAN'T AFFORD MEDICINE
RETROACTIVELY BUSINESSES CAN'T
SURVIVE RETROACTIVELY NOW THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE DECIDED TO
PUSHING APPROACH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OWN LABOR
DEPARTMENT REJECTED IS
UNWORKABLE SO IF THE REPUBLICAN
PLAN CAN'T WORK THEN THE STARK
REALITY IS THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PLAN REMAINS CUT IN OFF THE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS. WHAT KIND OF
LEADER PUNISHES THE UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS IN THE MIDST OF A
CRISIS THE HARM TO FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES TO NOT BE A RADICAL.
IN THE LAST RECESSION WE LET
EMERGENCY UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
LEFT AND THE HARM TO
INDIVIDUALS AND RETAILERS WAS
IMMEDIATE. AND SUBSTANTIAL. IN
ILLINOIS. IF REPUBLICANS LEFT
TO SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS EXPIRE.
THE AVERAGE BENEFIT WILL BE CUT
BY 63% HARDWORKING AMERICANS
DESERVE RELIEF WE MUST PROTECT
WORKERS AND FAMILIES WE MUST DO
IT NOW THERE'S NO TIME TO WAIT
THERE'S NO TIME LEFT NOW IS THE
TIME AND WE MUST ACT
IMMEDIATELY. NOW I'D LIKE TO
PREVENT REPRESENTATIVE KILLED
THE FROM YOU SHOULD. THANK YOU
OF CHAIRMAN DAVIS AND THE
SPEAKER PELOSI CHAIRMAN NEIL-
JOINED BY MISTER EVANS TO BOTH
OF WAYS AND MEANS COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR EFFORTS
WE'RE HERE TODAY WITH ONE
MESSAGE FOR THE PRESIDENT. AND
FOR THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
TCH MCCONNELL DO YOUR JOB.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE. AT
RISK OF LOSING EVERYTHING THAT
THEY'VE WORKED FOR. IN THE ONLY
THING HOLDING. THEM TOGETHER
HAS BEEN THIS UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THE ONLY THING. IT
PREVENTS THEM FROM KEEPING IT
IS THE ACTION OF THIS PRESIDENT
AND OF THE UNITED STATES SENATE
COVID NINETEEN IS
SIMULTANEOUSLY AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS. AND HEALTH CRISIS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES.
FORTY MILLION AMERICAN WORKERS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS. THESE
SIMULTANEOUS CRISES ARE FAR
FROM OVER. YESTERDAY FOR THE
EIGHTEENTH WE CAN ROLL OVER A
MILLION PEOPLE FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ARE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE NATIONALLY IS
OVER 11% WORSE THAN THE GREAT
RECESSION. IN MY HOME STATE.
TWO OF THE HARDEST HIT STATES
TWO MILLION MICHIGANDERS HAVE
LOST THEIR JOBS WE HAVE PASSED
LEGISLATION. WE'RE NOT JUST
HAVING A CONVERSATION WE'RE
LEGISLATING. SOMEONE ONCE TOLD
ME A LONG TIME AGO YOU CAN'T
FUND A CONVERSATION WE PASSED
THE BILL THAT PROTECTS THESE
IMPORTANT. IS IMPORTANT
BENEFITS AND IN ADDITION TO
THAT PROVIDES OTHER CRITICAL
SUPPORT PROTESTING FOR
FRONTLINE WORKERS FOR STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR SCHOOLS.
IN EXTEND THAT SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR A WEEK BENEFIT FOR
MONTHS REPUBLICANS HAVE FAILED
TO ACT THEY KNOW EVERYTHING
THEY NEED TO KNOW TO MAKE A
DECISION ON THIS QUESTION. BUT
THE HEROES ACT. SITS ON MITCH
MCCONNELL'S DESK GATHERING DUST.
WHY ISN'T THERE ANY EMPATHY
FROM THESE REPUBLICANS MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS ARE ABOUT TO LOSE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY'VE WORKED
FOR. AND NOT BE ABLE TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE NOT TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES. IN THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS ARE LITERALLY
DINING ON ALLIGATOR SAUSAGE. IN
CRAB BISQUE WHILE AMERICANS ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT FOOD ON
THEIR OWN TABLES BECAUSE OF
THEIR IN ACTION WE NOW FIND
OURSELVES STARING DOWN
TOMORROW'S DEADLINE. WHERE
AMERICANS WILL STOP GETTING
THAT ESSENTIAL LIFELINE THIS
PANDEMIC IS NOT OVER THIS IS NO
TIME. TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN. SO
EVEN AS- WE BEGIN TO OPEN
REOPEN PARTS OF THE ECONOMY IN
SOME CASES OBVIOUSLY TOO
QUICKLY BUT EVEN WHEN THE
ECONOMY DOES BEGIN. TO
REESTABLISH ITSELF. THE JOBS
WON'T COME BACK. AS FAST AS
THEY WERE LOST UNEMPLOYMENT
WILL STILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM THE HIGHEST LEVELS
WE'VE SEEN. SINCE AND NOW CLIP
SAYING THE LEVELS OF THE GREAT
RECESSION. WITHOUT THIS ACTION
TWENTY FIVE MILLION AMERICANS
AGAIN COULD LOSE EVERYTHING
THAT THEY'VE WORKED THEIR LIVES
TO CREATE. EVERYONE OF THESE
DOLLARS MATTERS TO THESE
FAMILIES AND IS CHAIRMAN NEIL
SAID THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
SUPPORTING THOSE FAMILIES. BUT
THIS SUPPORTS THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY IMAGINE TAKING AWAY
THIS LIFELINE IT NOT ONLY PUT
THOSE FAMILIES IN JEOPARDY. BUT
IT TAKES SIGNIFICANT SPENDING
POWER OUT OF THE ECONOMY
WITHOUT THIS UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. UNEMPLOYMENT GOES UP
IN THIS COUNTRY AND THE PROBLEM
GETS. WE WERE CHATTING BEFORE
COMING OUT HERE ALL OF US FOR
THE MOST PART THE MAJORITY OF
THE CALLS WE GET HAVE TO DO
WITH UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND
I JUST WANNA. I JUST WANT TO
MENTION A COUPLE THIS WITH RICK
FROM BAY CITY MICHIGAN WROTE TO
ME TO SAY QUOTE PLEASE VOTE TO
EXTEND THE SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
UNEMPLOYMENT. IT'S BEEN A MUCH
NEEDED LIFELINE IT HELPS WITH
BASIC NEEDS LIKE HOUSING IN
MEDICINE WE NEARLY LOST THEIR
HOME IN EVERYTHING WE DO NOT
KNOW WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
WITHOUT THAT EXTRA SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS STOPPING THESE PAYMENTS
SEEMS CRUEL. WE'RE BARELY
HANGING ON JEFFREY FROM SAGINAW
ROAD TO ME BASICALLY THE SAME
STORY HE SAID I'M STILL MAKING
FAR LESS THAT I'M DID BUT I'M
AT LEAST ABLE TO GET BY CRYSTAL
FROM BURTON SAID. I FEAR MY
CHILDREN AND I ARE GOING TO BE
LEFT HOMELESS AND WITHOUT FOOD.
I JUST DON'T KNOW TO WHAT WHAT
ELSE WE DO. THESE ARE THE
STAKES. THESE ARE THE STATES
THIS IS ABOUT REAL AMERICAN
LIVES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
AFFECTED. PERMANENTLY WE WANT
TO CREATE. THE FIRST GENERATION
OF ANOTHER ROUND OF MULTIPLE
GENERATION. POVERTY NO WE DON'T
KNOW WE HAVE ACTED. THE LEADER
IN THIS EFFORT. AND ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS HAS BEEN OUR LEADER THE
SPEAKER. AND SHE HAS BEEN JUST-
JUST DOGGED IN HER
DETERMINATION TO GET THIS DONE
SO IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BRING
FORWARD OUR LEADER THE SPEAKER
SPEAKER PELOSI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MR KELLY I
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN NEIL THANK
YOU A GERMAN DAVIS THANK YOU
ALL FOR FOCUSING ON THIS VERY
CENTRAL ISSUE AN ISSUE THAT
GOES TO THE HEART. OF THE
KITCHEN TABLE CONCERNS OF
AMERICA'S WORKING FAMILIES WE
CAN TALK ABOUT A NUMBER OF
THINGS THE- TIME. EVERYTHING IS
ABOUT TIME THE TIME THAT IT'S
TAKEN FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
RECOGNIZE. THAT YOU SHOULD WEAR
A MASK OF THE TIME IT TOOK
NINETY EIGHT DAYS JUST UNDER
HOT UP AT A HUNDRED DAYS. TO
REACH OF ONE MILLION PEOPLE
INFECTED IN THE UNITED STATES
HALF THAT TIME TO REACH TWO
MILLION FORTY THREE DAYS TWENTY
SEVEN DAYS TO REACH THREE
MILLION PEOPLE. SIXTEEN. IS TO
READ FOUR MILLION. TERRIBLE THE
MISSION CHAIRMAN DAY THANK YOU
COME EVAN MR KILLED N. AND
MISTER NEIL FOR BRINGING US
HERE. WE I KNOW HE'S ONE OPEN
THE SCHOOL ONE OPEN THE FETUS
BY AND YET. AND YET AND YET
DELAY DISTORTION THE NILE HAS
TAKEN US TO A PLACE WHERE WE
HAVE FOUR MILLION PEOPLE AND
THEIR MANY OTHER CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE OF STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVING TO FIRE
PEOPLE AND THE LIST IS ALONG
ONE OF CONCERNS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT MISTER
DAVIS RIGHT CALLED RELATE
INJUSTICES AND HOW THEY
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THE
REST BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
FOCUSING ON THIS ONE SUBJECT
THE EXTENSION OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
THIS IS CENTRAL TO THE WELL
BEING OF AMERICA'S AND WHAT DO
THE REPUBLICANS AND THE WHITE
HOUSE HAVE AGAINST WORKING
FAMILIES IN OUR COUNTRY. THAT
THEY WOULD WATCH THEM. SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS OF SO WELL
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
SUSTENANCE. THIS IS THERE OTHER
THINGS CAN IN HERE TOO IT'S
ABOUT PAYING THE RENT. AND IT'S
ABOUT BUYING FOOD SO WITH THIS
PACKAGE WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
VERGE OF THE DIRECTION WE HAVE
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN STARTED AT
FOOD INSECURE IN AMERICA WE
NEED THE ON THE- OF FOOD STAMPS
IN THE REST AND THEY RESENT THE
FACT. WE HAD LEGISLATION IN
HEROES ACT AND INDEPENDENTLY TO
HELP WITH RENT SO THAT PEOPLE
ARE NOT EVICTED AND WE HAVE
THIS MONEY IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS SO I THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THE WAYS AND MEANS COMMITTEE
FOR ALWAYS RECOGNIZE. ALWAYS
READ THE CONNECTION BETWEEN OUR
POLICY AND THE HEALTH AND LAW
AT LIVELIHOOD THE LIVES AND
LIVELIHOODS OF AMERICA'S
WORKING FAMILIES. ENSLAVEMENT
AS AGAIN AS MISTER KILDEE SAID
WE HEAR COLD ALL THE TIME
PEOPLE CRYING ON THE PHONE
CRYING OR TV QUITE THERE IN
PAIN THERE IT'S ABOUT THEIR
DIGNITY AND HOW THEY MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR- CHILDREN. AND
WHY I WANTED BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE DERELICT IN
THEIR DUTY TAKING OFF FOR THE
WEEKEND INSTEAD OF BEING READY
ALL THESE MONTHS WITHOUT
PREPARING SOMETHING TO BEGIN
WITH WHEN WE HAD OUR OFFERS
THEY MAKE THEIR OFFER NOW TWO
MONTHS AND AN EIGHT TEN DAYS
HAVE GONE BY AND WHERE ARE THEY
AND WHERE IS THEIR OFFER WHICH
EARLIER THIS WEEK THEY SAID WE
WOULD SEE A TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT. HOURS THEY'RE IN
DISARRAY AND THEIR DISARRAY IS
CAUSING GREAT GREAT DAMAGE TO
AMERICA'S WORKING FAMILIES THIS
IS AN ALARM THAT NEEDS TO BE
SENT SOUNDED AS LOUDLY AS
POSSIBLE. ABOUT WHAT ARE WE
DOING HERE. IF WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE
LOST THEIR JOBS THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN IN THIS MR.
DAVIS SAID. THEY TELL THEM TO
GO TO WORK. GO TO WORK HERE IN
THE CENTRAL WORTH YOU MUST GO
TO WORK. AND WHEN YOU GO TO
WORK AND THEY'RE NO PROTECTIONS
YOU HAVE NO RECOURSE. AND IF
YOU DON'T GO TO WORK BECAUSE
YOU'RE AFRAID THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BRING SOME. THE INFECTION
HOME TO YOUR CHILDREN YOU DON'T
GET UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. BUT
MR OF MR NAILED A CHECK
DISTINGUISHED CHAIRMAN HE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THERE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THE MOST. AS
A COUNTER BY THE REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE THERE FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE MOST. SOON THEY TALK
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS I
WANT TO REVIEW THE FACT THAT
THEY PUT TWO TRILLION DOLLARS
ON TO THE NATIONAL DEBT. TO
GIVE A TAX BREAK TO THE WEALTHY
83% OF THE BENEFITS TO THE TOP
1% I'LL CLOSE PRAYERFULLY.
QUOTING SENATE DUSTIN SOME OF
YOU HEAR ME SAY THIS ALMOST
EVERY DAY. THAT DUSTIN
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED YEARS AGO. HE
SAID ANY GOVERNMENT THAT IS NOT
FORMED TO PROMOTE JUSTICE IS
JUST A BUNCH OF THESE. LET'S
USE OUR TIME. TO REMOVE ALL
DOUBT THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING BY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SO THEY CAN MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILIES THE
BODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT BEING
FAMILY FRIENDLY. LET'S NOT
SQUAWK ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS WITH THAT I YIELD BACK
TO THE DISTANCE TO. THE OR
WHOEVER'S. LEADING THE WAY HERE.
THE QUESTIONS QUESTIONS. WILL
PASS A BILL TO END OF THE SHORT
TERM THE NEW ALL OF THESE
BENEFITS SO THAT THEY DON'T
LAST FOR AMERICANS. THIS WAS
WHICH INTENTIONALLY WEEK TO
HOLD ON THE PLANET. YEAH IF
THERE IS A- WE HAVE BUT WE TO
STAY SENATE IN THEIR LIFE WHAT
YOU WANT MORE MONEY FOOD. WE
HAVE HOUSE IN THEIR WHAT YOU
WANT MONEY FOR. WE HAVE THIS
BENEFIT IN THERE THERE IS. I
WOULD BE VERY MUCH AVERSE TO
SEPARATING THIS OUT AND LOSE
ALL LEVERAGE FOR ALL MEETING
ALL OF THE OTHER NEEDS IT'S A
FRAUDULENT. TACTIC AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO YOU AN ONBOARD.
QUESTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
MEETING THE NEEDS OF AMERICA'S
WORKING FAMILIES BUT WE HAVE
I'M GLAD YOU'RE HAVING HEARING.
TO KEEP THE SPOTLIGHT ON IT.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF PUTTING
THEY COULD HAVE DONE. THEY
COULD HAVE DONE THEIR JOB AS
YOU SAID DO YOUR JOB. I MEAN.
THIS IS DERELICTION OF DUTY AND
A RESPONSIBILITY AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND NOW WE YOU'RE SAYING
WHAT YOU JUST BAIL THEM OUT. SO
THEY CAN IGNORE ALL THE NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE FOR TESTING ALL
THE NEEDS WE HAVE FOR STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALL THE NEEDS
WE HAVE. FOR FOOD SECURITY ALL
THE NEEDS WE HAVE FOR- SHOULD
BENEFIT THAT IS IN THE BILL ALL
THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE- A FOR.
VOTE BY MAIL AND OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT WE HAVE. THAT
ARE ABOUT JUSTICE. ARE YOU
CONSIDERING. EXTENDING FROM OR
TWO ONE CONTINUE TO. ONE BEING.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE EVERY OF
IT THEY NEED TO MAKE A DECISION.
NUMBER. ONE WHAT DO PEOPLE. ONE
HUNDRED POINT YEAH. BUT A GOOD.
GOOD GIVES LEGISLATURE IF YOU
DON'T WITH THE TIME CREDITS
IT'S REAL A GOOD FUSELAGE OVER
IF THE TACTIC IT WOULD NOT
HONOR OTHERS WITH. FOR NOT
PARTY THEIR CATHOLIC. MANY FOR
EDUCATION AND MORE MONEY FOR
GBP INSTEAD OF ROCK WE BRING
THE END OF. IN BENEFIT OF
ANOTHER SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS DO
YOU THINK IT IS POSSIBLE TO
EXTEND EXTEND THAT BENEFIT AT
THAT LEVEL AND KEEP THEMSELVES
WITH THAT INTERVIEW. AND IF WE
SAID TO THE REPUBLICANS I WOULD
SAY SOMETHING. THIS IS DEADLY
SERIOUS A HEALTH IS BURNING
DOWN IN TERMS OF THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY OF AMERICA'S FAMILIES
AND THESE PEOPLE ARE SETTLING
WHEREVER THEY MAY BE THIS
WEEKEND SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WELL THEY WANT TO DO A TRILLION
DOLLAR SO HOW COULD WE DO SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THOSE IN
THE MOST NEED MMHM WHEN THEY
GOT OTHER THINGS THEY WANT TO
DO. THAT'S WHAT CHUCKANUT
DISTINGUISHED LEADER AND I SAID
TO THEM PUT YOUR BILL ON PAPER
PUT YOUR BILL ON PAPER AND THEN
WE'LL SEE WHAT YOU HAVE
INCLUDED AND WHAT YOU HAVE LEFT
OUT AND THEN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL SEE WHAT YOU HAVE
INCLUDED AND WHAT YOU HAVE LEFT
OUT. BUT I'M TELLING YOU YOU
CAN'T HAVE ANY MORE PATIENCE
YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A
WONDERFUL THING I READ. IT'S
AMAZING HOW MUCH PATIENCE
PEOPLE CAN HAVE WITH OTHER
PEOPLE SUFFERING. WELL WE DON'T
HAVE THAT PATIENCE ON OUR SIDE
OF THE AISLE AND SO FOR THEM TO
SAY A TRILLION DOLLARS WHEN
THEY SPENT TWO TRILLION DOLLARS
YOU GET A TAX CUT TO THE
RICHEST PEOPLE IN AMERICA 83%
OF THE BENEFITS. TO THE TOP ONE.
AND THEY BOUGHT IT. KEEP IT ON
THE BACKS OF OUR CHILDREN FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF. OF IT
LET US SEE WHAT THEIR TRILLION
DOLLARS GETS THEM AWARDED THE
EXCLUDING THEY HAVE NOTHING FOR
STATE AND LOCAL WHERE PEOPLE
ARE. WORKING HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS FOOD SUPPLIERS.
TRANSIT WORKERS TEACHERS
TEACHERS TEACHERS SANITATION
WORKERS PEOPLE WHO MAKE. A
SYSTEM RUN. OVER HALF A MILLION
AND HALF OF THEM HAVE BEEN
FIRED ALREADY BECAUSE OF THE
NEEDS OF. OF CORONAVIRUS THE
EXPENSES OF A CORONAVIRUS AND
THE REVENUE LOST BECAUSE OF
CORONA TAKE THAT OUT LET THOSE
PEOPLE GO OKAY SO NOW THEY
DON'T HAVE JOBS THEY PROBABLY
HAD TO GO ON UNEMPLOYMENT.
RIGHT SO WHAT MONEY HAVE THEY
SAY. AND THEN WE HAVE TESTING
TESTING TESTING THEY SHUT DOWN
THEIR CAFETERIA THE MINUTE
SOMEBODY GOT A- INCEPTED IN
THE- US. WHITE HOUSE COMPLEX
THEY SHUT IT DOWN AND TESTING
ENTRANCES WHY CAN'T THEY PUT
THAT MONEY THERE FOR THE
STATE'S IN A SUBSTANTIAL WAY
WITH THE FUTURE PLAN TO DO
THAT. SO WHAT MONEY DO THEY
HAVE THEIR FOR THAT. THEN WE
HAVE THE MONEY FOR A FOR A
RENTAL ASSISTANCE IN MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE AND- OF- FOOD
STAMPS AS I KEEP SAYING I ONE
THING I JUST CAN'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THEY COULD EVEN SHOW THEIR
FACES BY FERN. FOOD STAMPS YOU
WANT MORE MONEY FOR FOOD STAMPS
WHY WOULD WE WHY WOULD WE DO
THAT WELL. BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
HUNGRY IN AMERICA DOESN'T THAT
MOTIVATE YOU SELL A TRILLION
DOLLARS THAT ARE STILL THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION AND LANE
IT'S EVERYTHING WE NEED IT'S
NOTHING EXTRA. SO LET'S SEE
WHERE THERE'S TRILLION DOLLAR
TAKES THEM AND NOT HAVE THEM
USE THAT IS THE REASON WHY THEY
CAN'T GIVE. AMERICA'S WORKING
FAMILIES. SIX SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS. DON'T GET ME STARTED
THAT SIX. YOU KNOW. I THINK
IT'S A- IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THOUGH EVEN IF SOMEHOW. EVEN OF
SOME OTHER REPUBLICANS CAN'T
CONJURE SOME EMPATHY FOR THESE
FAMILIES WHICH IS HARD TO
COMPREHEND. THE AUTO AT LEAST
BE ABLE TO COMPREHEND THE FACT
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
ECONOMY HAS BEEN BARELY HELD
TOGETHER IS BECAUSE THESE
FAMILIES HAVE HAD THIS
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT AND THE
SPENDING POWER TO GO DOWN TO
THE CORNER GROCERY STORE. IN TO
PAY THEIR RENT IN TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR FAMILIES THAT MONEY
GOES DIRECTLY INTO THE U. S.
ECONOMY SO EVEN IF THEY CAN'T
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO HAVE
SYMPATHY AND EMPATHY FOR THE
FAMILIES THAT WOULD BE HURT AND
HARM SO MUCH BY THIS THE OUT OF
AT LEAST AND ROLL. IN AN ENTRY
LEVEL ECONOMICS CLASS AND
UNDERSTAND IF YOU TAKE THAT
MONEY OUT OF THE ECONOMY THIS
WHOLE HOUSE OF CARDS IS GOING
TO COLLAPSE AND THAT'S WHY THEY
NEED TO ACT NOW. AFTER THANK
YOU ON THE ON THE ISSUE OF
PRICE TAG- THE CURES ACT CAST
TWO MONTHS AGO FLOSS AND
CONDITIONS HAVE CHANGED ON THE
GROUND OBVIOUSLY IN A MUCH MORE
MONEY. ALSO LIKE IS THREE POINT
FORTY NOT GIVEN THAT THAT A LOT
OF. A LOT OF PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY ARE SUFFERING MORE THAN
WORKING ON. AND WE'RE WOULD
THAT BE I KNOW YOU. EDUCATION
LEVEL. MAY USE YOUR SESSION TO
KEEP IT FROM WHAT THE KILLED IT
WAS SET. WE A CONSUMER ECONOMY
OUR ECONOMY IT GROWS AND
SUCCEEDS IN THE STRENGTHENED BY
THE COMP THE CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE THAT IS THERE. THEY
SHOULD KNOW THAT AT THE SAME
TIME AS THEIR SPENDING
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BOLSTER
THE STOCK MARKET SO MORE IT HAS
THE FLOOR. AND THAT'S NOT A BAD
THING. WE SHOULD BE SPENDING
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO HAVE
THE FLOOR FOR AMERICA'S WORKING
FAMILIES BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO BUT IT'S ALSO THE
MOST A PRAGMATIC THING TO DO IN
ORDER WITH YOU PUT MONEY INTO
BUSINESSES IF THERE'S AN- YEAH
I GOT NO CUOMERS. IT'S NO USE
HAVING MONEY TO PAY THE RENT
AND THE STAFF IF YOU WANT IF
THERE'S NO BUSINESS SO THIS
MONEY IS SPENT. IT'S NECESSARY
NEEDED IT SPENT IT INJECTS
DEMAND INTO THE ECONOMY AND IT
CREATES JOBS SO I JUST WANT TO
GO BACK TO YOUR POINT. OKAY ONE
EDUCATION FOR EXAMPLE WE NEED
MUCH MORE MONEY WE HAD A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN FOR
EDUCATION WE ALL WE ALSO KNEW
THAT THAT WASN'T REALLY QUITE
ENOUGH BUT WE WERE TRYING TO BE.
LEAN AND MEAN WITH THE BUDGET
AND- THEY CAME IN WITH A
HUNDRED AND FIVE THIS WEEK AND
THEY SAID WELL YOU HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED. BUT OF COURSE YOU HAVE
TO SEE WHERE THEY WANT TO SPEND
THAT MONEY BUT WE PROBABLY NEED
DOUBLE THAT MUCH. AT LEAST
DOUBLE THAT MUCH FOR EDUCATION
FOR ONE THING. BUT BY AND
LARGE- WE HAVE WE'RE- WE'RE
PRETTY GOOD SHAPE WITH. WHAT WE
HAVE IN THE BUDGET IF WE COULD
SPEND IT NOW NOW THEY WANT TO
DO ZERO FOR STATE AND LOCAL.
REALLY TELL IT TO THE GOVERNORS
AND MAYORS ACROSS ITS COUNTY
EXECUTIVES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT MUCH
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE A TRILLION
DOLLARS. AND IF YOU SEE THEIR
TRILLION DOLLAR LIST. IT'S
REALLY GONNA BE A BIG
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY TO SEE WHO THEY- CUT OUT.
AND WHO THEY INCLUDE AND HOW
THEY WERE WILLING TO SPEND
DOUBLE THAT FOR TAX CUTS FOR
THE RICH FRIENDS. ANYBODY WHO
CAN. MINS AGO I HEARD YOU SAY.
DIRECTED TO YOU BUT ANYBODY CAN
ANSWER AND I'M FOLLOWING UP ON
THAT QUESTION I HEARD YOU SAY
NO MULTIPLE TIMES BUT ISN'T
THIS ISSUE ON A DIFFERENT LEVEL
IN THE SENSE THAT IT IS
IMMEDIATE IT IS GOING TO EXPIRE
AND THAT SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS WHILE ALSO IMPORTANT. V.
FUNDING FOR ELECTIONS AND
FUNDING FOR EDUCATION ISN'T
GOING TO HAVE THE FACT THAT MR
KILL THE HEAD HAS DESCRIBED HIS
CONSTITUENTS ARE WARD WHAT IF
YOU WERE GOING TO BE AFFECTED
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH YOU I
THINK I'M WAY. OF KLEIN
COULDN'T PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
FOR YOUR CHILDREN YOU MIGHT BE
THINKING A DIFFERENT WAY THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE TO HAVE THESE-
ACTUALLY THE SAFETY. NET FOR
THE CAPITALIST SYSTEM. AS
THINKING. IT'S A CAT. SYSTEM SO
NET. SO THAT THEY CAN WILL AND
DEAL IN FREE WHEN AND THEN IN
THE CYCLE OF THINGS WHEN
PEOPLE. ARE NEEDED HELP THERE'S
A SAFETY NET. FOR THE
CAPITALIST SYSTEM SO IF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A CABLE SYSTEM WHICH
I FULLY SUPPORT THEM ONE TO
STRENGTHEN. WE STRENGTHEN IT BY
MAKING SURE REMOVING ALL DOUBT.
OF THAT WHEN THINGS GO ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER. PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO
THEIR CHILDREN WHY THEY DON'T
HAVE FOOD ON THE- ON THE TABLE.
SO WHAT THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT SO WITH A YOU ONE
HAPPY WAS THE HOW MANY PEOPLE
BE ON THE STREET BEING AFFECTED
BECAUSE THEY- CANNOT. PAY THE
RENT. AND THEN THEY CAN PAY THE
RENT. EXPONENTIALLY BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS I'M JUST GOING
TO LIGHTEN UP THE MOOD HERE.
AMID THIS I. CARL REINER GREAT
YOU KNOW YOU ALL TOO YOUNG TO
KNOW BUT HE WAS A GREAT
COMEDIAN THE REDNESS SON ROB
REINER MEATHEAD MAYBE IF TWO
YOUNG FOR A LONG TIME ANYWAY HE
DIED GREAT COMEDIAN IN HIS
NINETIES NINETY EIGHT YEARS OLD.
SO I CALLED HIS SON ROB WHO IS
A COMEDIAN TO A COLORADO. RON
RON DARLING THIS IS NANCY
PELOSI I'M CALLING TO WISH YOU
AND MICHELLE. MY CONDOLENCES
I'M SO SAD YOUR FATHER WAS SO
FUNNY AND SO WONDERFUL HAD THE
OCCASION TO HEAR IN THE BACK OF
A MEMBER OF. THIS MAN SAYS. I
THINK YOU HAVE THE WRONG NUMBER
IF. I SAID REALLY AND I'M SO
SORRY I THOUGHT THIS IS ROB
RUNNERS HE SAID WELL YOU KNOW I
KNOW CARL REINER IS IN THE
RUNNERS BUT I THINK YOU HAVE
THE WRONG NUMBER A CIVIL I'M SO
SORRY. WHEN I TULSA MUSTAPHA
VALDEZ. AND HE SAYS BUT I'M SO
GLAD YOU CALLED ME I HAVE ONE
QUESTION FOR YOU I SAID WHAT IS
THAT THEY SAID AM I GONNA GET
MY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS. AT I'M
VERY PROUD OF OUR I THOUGHT IT
WAS GREAT I HAVE FOUR DAUGHTERS
TWO GREAT TWO GRANDDAUGHTERS
AND- I THOUGHT SHE WAS JUST
GREAT IT WAS YOU KNOW WHAT
WHICH HE SAID IS WHAT WE ALL
KNOW A PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO GIVE LICENSE TO
PEOPLE TO SPEAK THAT WAY WHO
ARE AT EASE WITH THAT KIND OF
DISRESPECT CONDESCENSION AND
THE REST IN IT KEEPING WITH THE
PRESIDENT WAS SAYING ABOUT HIS
FEAR MONGERING FOR A WOMEN WHO
LIVE IN SUBURBIA AND HOW WE
TREAT IT THAT FEARMONGERING
DISC- DISCRIMINATION.
DISRESPECT CONDESCENSION I WAS
VERY PROUD. THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH IN MY DAY JOB.
YEAH. YEAH.
SO.
YEAH OKAY. OKAY YEAH.
EXACTLY AT THE END YEAH SO. HE
WOULD BE ALL RIGHT. RIGHT I
DON'T. IT WOULD BE YEAH EXACTLY
BUT YEAH IT WAS. OKAY YEAH YEAH.
YEAH THANK. UHHUH. YEAH YEAH
YEAH OKAY. YEAH YEAH ONE HI.
THANK YOU YEAH. EVERY FIVE
HUNDRED EVERYTHING. OKAY. YEAH
OKAY THANK YOU OF PHILADELPHIA.
TO YEAH. OKAY SHE WAS A. OKAY
YE